- [Blonde] Have you ever
slept with a Black guy?
- [Brunette] No, but I really want to.
- [Blonde] Me too.
- I told myself this morning
I wasn't gonna fall in love.
- Don't hold me back,
dawg, don't hold me back!
- Hello, sir, I would like a rum and coke.
- Okay!
- That's okay, I've got beers.
- Oh
kay!
(hip hop music)
(trills lips)
(laughing)
- Well well
- (beep) Mexicans.
- Whoa, man.
Do not get me started on the Mexicans.
- Hey, I was just sayin'
they hold the Goddamn economy together.
- You know what man, damn straight.
If 12% of the Mexicans
that live in this country
stop working, just 12%,
the USA would shut down.
- I don't even care who hears me.
- Nope.
They, they, they, they
worked their asses off
and they got strong family values.
- Essential immigrants.
(beers clink)
- Hey, speaking of immigrants,
how about them Asians?
- (beep) you know what brother?
You wanna light that fuse
then you better stand back,
'cause I got something I wanna say
about those mother (beep).
- I got three words for you:
estudious, hard working, industrious.
- Damn straight.
Asians are the highest
income, best educated
and the fastest growing
racial group in the US of A.
- Plus got the highest percentage
of college graduates in the country.
Good for them.
- And I, maybe this makes me sound racist,
but those mother (beep),
they're gonna save the country.
- There it is.
You went and said it.
(beers clink)
- I just said...
I just came right the
(beep) out and said it.
- It was in everyone's mind.
- But I'm the one who said it.
Hey, and you know what?
While we're at it, I'm
gonna break my spine.
Tip, tap, dancin' wancin', prancing
around the elephant in the room.
- Yep.
- Blacks.
- (beep) Blacks.
And You know what you done done did?
You opened up the flood
gates now my friend.
Released the Kraken.
God damn victims of
institutionalized racismey
It is not all that.
They overcame the slavery
and the segregation
just to become CEOs and entrepreneurs.
- And hey, one of them's
the gosh darn President!
- And, I mean, that's
just true right there.
That's just historical fact,
man, can't even argue that.
(laughs)
- Oh, how about the Indians?
- (beep) Native Americans.
- I-I-I-I-I don't know if I
would get in trouble these days
for saying something like
this, but they were here first.
- It may be unpopular, but it's true.
- We came to this country
and we steam rolled on
in and we genocided them.
I mean, hell we owe 'em something.
- There you go.
(beers clink)
I gotta tell you, man, that's not bad
for a non-alcoholic beer.
- Not bad at all.
All right, I gotta go
home, take care of my kids.
- How many of 'em you got now?
- Just adopted the 11th.
Can't help myself.
Man that's always what happens
when you volunteer for the
earthquake relief in Haiti.
- Yep, yep, yep.
- And what you gonna do?
- And what you gon' do?
- [Peele] You know my wife
makes 2/3 of what I make.
- [Key] What? Y'all got the same job, man.
That's just patently unfair.
- [Peele] That's right,
we're both librarians.
(burps the word nerds)
- You all right?
- I'm okay.
- I just finished episode four.
- Okay. So the Lannisters
are the blonde people
and the female Lannister
is married to Robert
Barantheon, who is the king.
- Is it Barantheon or Baratheon?
- Right.
- And then the other
blonde girl is the uh...
- Can I get you something?
- Oh, oh I don't know, three
Kamakaze shots, whatever.
Oh my God, I can't
believe he just did that.
- What's that?
- Served me before you guys.
I'm really against that, I'm so sorry.
- That's okay, we, uh, we've got beers.
- No, I mean, I'm sorry about everything.
- Oh, that's fine, it's fine.
- No, no.
It's been a hundred years of not fine.
I mean, 20 years ago
you guys wouldn't have
even been allowed in here.
- 20 years, that would be 1992.
- It was really beautiful...
- Oh, she's done.
- That just happened, didn't it?
Yeah.
- [Key] Wow. Amazing.
- [Peele] So the Lannisters.
- [Key] She's the queen,
- [Peele] Jamie Lannister
is the other one.
- Jamie is the...
- Yo yo yo, what up man?
Hey, gimme another lager, know mean?
Yeah.
Spilled my last one on my Tribe shirt.
You believe that?
But whatevs, got this thing in
'93 Midnight Marauders tour.
Check that out, it's everywhere, oh man.
- Hey, who's your
favorite member of Tribe?
- Smoke, Smoke, Smokey!
Know mean?
Love him dude.
More behind the scenes but he was like...
All right, good, see
you guys around though.
- Mhmm, okay
- Cool.
One more, one more, one more.
Come on, son.
Boom.
All right, late.
- Oh, he spun.
- Wow.
- He spun.
- Second person to not wait
for their drink by the way.
- Yep.
Okay, let me ask you this then.
What's with the barbarian dude
who looks like a huge Dave Navarro?
Who's that guy.
- Oh, I need a drink.
(fatigued laugh)
Just finished Amistad.
I saw it three times
and I'll see it a hundred more times
because like, I'm happy to do it.
If that's what those guys went through
I'm happy to sit through it, you know,
300 more times or whatever,
you know, it takes.
- Yeah, it's, it's uh,
it's pretty intense.
- My thing is, it's like,
I don't think one person
should own another person, period.
- I'm glad that that's what
you got from that movie.
- Yeah. I mean, I don't care
when it happened, all right?
It should never happen.
It should never occur.
But like, I'm preaching to the choir.
You guys know what I'm talking about.
- Yeah, we do.
- Yeah, we really do.
- I'm like, it's like, why
would anybody even do that?
I'm like, no, you di-in't.
No, you di-in't.
What you doing, girl, no, you di-in't.
I'm ashamed.
- You know what it's it's
really probably okay,
because you weren't there.
- Okay, well we can come
up with excuses all day.
All day.
- Let's, let's, let's,
let's just not do that.
Let's not do that.
- Look, hey, bottom line:
we cool, right?
- [Peele] Yeah.
- [Dreadlocks Man] Ight.
- [Key] Yeah, we are cool.
- We kiggity cool?
- [Key] Yes.
- What's that?
- Didn't say anything.
- Nothing.
- Oh, you didn't...
All right, four more years.
- Hey, if it makes you
guys feel any better
Black people make me really uncomfortable.
- Thank you.
- [Key] Oh, man, I really
had to get the house.
- I'm just glad you came out.
Appreciate it for real.
- Check this girl out, man.
She is fine.
- She ight.
- Really?
- Hey man, I am going
to go to the bathroom.
- Okay man, see you in a minute
- You know what?
I told myself this morning
I wasn't gonna fall in love.
You went and made me break my only rule.
I'm gonna take that right quick.
I am going to take that.
I'm going to use that.
Okay.
(laughs awkwardly)
- Oh, hey, what's up man?
Got her number huh?
- Yeah. Cheyenne.
- Oh, is that her name?
Yeah, she was fly.
- Th-that, that, that's the
girl I was talking about.
- Oh snap, are you serious?
- Yeah, dude.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- It ain't no thing, forget it.
There's plenty of hotties here.
- I just thought you was
talking about someone else.
- Check her out.
(ominous sound)
- I'm not a sports man,
but I think me and you
could touch down later, if
you know what I'm sayin'.
(laughs)
Am I being stupid?
But for real though, just
gimme your number, whatever.
Thank you, girl.
I'm gonna take that from you.
- How, how did you get over here so fast?
- Huh?
- Nothing.
It just seemed like you...
- [Reporter] The death
toll has climbed to seven
the second day in Texas...
- Damn, that reporter is smokin' hot.
(ominous sound)
What the (beep)?
(keys clang)
(door slams)
(soft piano music)
(ominous sound)
No.
No!
(soft piano music)
(laughing incredulously)
(ominous sound)
(squeaky door sound)
(ominous music)
No.
(door opens)
- [Girlfriend] Hey baby!
- How you doing that?
- Honey what's wrong?
- Baby, I love you.
I'm sorry.
I was out, I was looking
at other women tonight
but you are all there is.
All right, I love you.
(high pitched ominous noise)
(hip hop music)
(hubbub of bar crowd)
(clears throat)
- Hey, what, what, what,
what can I get you?
- Hello sir.
I would like a rum and Coke.
- Rum and Coke coming up.
(excessive groaning in pain)
- Where you from?
All right, babe.
I'ma see you on a dance floor, girl.
Oh!
(groans in pain)
- Rum and Coke, that's gonna be $8.00.
$8.00, all right my good man.
Let me...
(breathes out in preparation)
(screams)
- Shh
- [Key] Woo!
Let me, I'ma got it, I got it.
(beep)
Aah!
(beep) my wallet!
- Hey, you all right?
You all right?
- Whoo!
(laughs)
I tell you what, third
time's the charm, brother.
(breathes repeatedly)
(screams)
Wallet!
- There it is, there it is.
- Yeah, just, just take the card out,
keep that open for me.
Can you hang on to that for me?
- Will do.
- In fact, let me get a
tequila shot, brother.
Actually make it two man.
One for me and one for you my good man.
(screams)
- Two tequila shots coming right up.
- How you doing girl?
All right, nectar of the gods up in here.
- [Bartender] All right.
- All right, let's get
that going with that.
All right, cheers!
- All right.
(glasses clink)
Cheers
(screams)
(puckers lips)
- Woo!
(screams)
- No, hold on.
There's more than one way to skin a cat.
- You want some help with that?
- Hold up, let me just
try to get up in here.
- Oh
(screams)
- That's burning my tongue!
- You know what?
- What?
- I'm gonna get you one of these.
- Yeah.
- Try that.
- There we...
All right, you a genius.
Let me get this going on here.
- This
- Mhmm.
- There you go.
(slurps)
- Woo!
- Viacom deals, my daughter.
Woo!
All right, muchas gracias.
- Hey.
So uh, I'm worried about you.
- Oh, I'm gonna tell you
what I'm worried about.
I'm worried that this
club ain't popping off
the way it should be.
What what?
Cause I, wait a second.
What?
Uh oh.
DJ, turn it up.
That's my track right there.
Ah-huh
(screams)
There it is!
(screaming)
(drink spilling)
(laughing)
- Hey man, a bar is not the
place for you to be right now.
(screams)
(crashing glass)
(wincing in pain)
- Hey, lemme get two
more shots of tequila.
- Uh uh.
Sorry pal, you're 86'ed
- What, how, eh, what,
that's preposterous...
- Let's go buddy.
(screaming)
- Be gentle with him.
- [Omar] I don't like this one.
(screaming)
- Oh, it hurts all over!
How you doing girl?
(screaming)
- First time, I think, it's like '87.
Two guys, heavyweight battle.
Yeah, no, it was the first
time in a heavyweight battle
that the two fighters
ended up getting married.
(putting on a different accent)
- Hello, my good sir.
I like to have two shots of tequila.
(cracking sound)
(screaming)
By the way..
(grunting)
- Omar!
- Oh man, that hurts.
- I want to know what's
going on with the huge woman.
And I want to know what the
deal is with the red witch lady.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- You know what I'm saying?
(women laughing)
Just stringing it out.
- [Blonde] I mean like have you?
Have you, have you ever
slept with a Black guy?
- [Brunette] No, but I really want to.
- [Blonde] Me too!
- Apparently it is like
a whole other thing
than sleeping with white men.
- Oh no, no.
I, I heard they're supposed to be
like way better at it or something.
- [Blonde] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
You heard that too?
I wonder if it's 'cause they have like,
like better rhythm, you know?
- [Brunette] Right?
Cause they're really good dancers.
- I mean, apparently
they have like bigger...
- Oh, way bigger penises, right?
(laughs)
- Yeah, I guess that's because of Africa.
- Yeah, like I feel like they're just,
they're like really
with you in the moment.
Like if they're gonna be with you,
they're in the here and now.
- [Blonde] Exactly, exactly.
Because they know that they basically
have no future.
Think about it.
(laughing)
- So sad.
- [Blonde] Think about it!
(laughing)
- I do feel like they treat their women
with just like, a little
bit more compassion, though.
- Yeah, like respect and stuff.
Oh, because their dads were never around!
- Oh right.
And they also a lot of
time on their hands.
'Cause even if they have kids,
they never go visit them.
- Oh, please, totally.
Baby daddy, that's a thing.
- Oh, that's in a dictionary now,
because of Black people.
- See?
Seriously, apparently,
Black guys just know
how to please white women, right?
Just like, way more than white men.
- Oh, well it's probably in their blood
'cause they're used to
pleasing their white masters.
- What?
- Okay, we're leaving.
- [Brunette] Totally.
- [Blonde] I am so desperate
to find out for myself.
(Blonde laughs)
- [Brunette] Me too.
- [Blonde] Right.
- Okay, um, I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
And I swear to you, if there's
a Black guy back there,
I'm gonna blow him.
(laughing)
- [Brunette] Get it.
- So unrelated, I now have
to go to the bathroom,
uh, because I've been
drinking coffee all day.
So I will be back in a little while.
- Well you know what,
let, let me go first.
I'll be about 30 seconds.
(hubbub of bar patrons)
- Ooh, ow, I hit my penis there.
- I'm sorry, I don't have any money, sir.
- I said it right there.
I was like, I was like,
I was like "You a woman."
"I'm a man, there's a
difference between..."
Oh, what?
- They bumping (beep) up in here.
Here it is, it's going off.
Yo.
Hey,
which one
a y'all mother (beep)
bumped me?
- I did.
The (beep) you're gonna do about it?
- Whazzat?
- Oh, I'll I tell you what
I'm gonna do about it!
- We don't wanna do this today!
Ooh yeah, yeah..
You lucky my friends holding me.
You lucky!
Cause I'll tear your head off!
Don't hold me back dawg!
Don't hold me back!
Oh, okay, then go for it.
- See, I know though,
if I were to lunge at you right now,
my friend right here,
he'd catch me at the last possible second.
- No, no, no, I won't.
- But my friend does have the cognizance
to tell me I don't need to be going up
and committing capital
murder up in a club tonight.
- Oh no, just knocking unconscious, dawg!
Bam!
Don't have to kill anybody.
No need for that, that's excessive.
Tear him up!
- I will....
W-w-w-wait-w-w-wait-lemme-lemme
finish my sentence!
I will,
Uh,
Oh!
Oh, snap!
You know what?
You lucky my boys using
his telekinetic powers
to hold me back right now!
- No, I'm not!
- Well maybe it's the type of telekinesis
that's a mutant power that
you didn't realize you had
until the moment it started.
- Oh, oh I got it.
I see, I see.
So you want me to hold you back.
(yelling)
- Oh, I'm a dragon!
Oh yeah, I wanna rip this...
I'm a lion.
I'm a tiger over here.
I'm a bear.
"Oh my!"
- I'll go crazy on you.
- Oh, I can't believe this man,
he's like, he's like a tornado up in here!
- Don't hold me back.
- I can't even believe
I can hold him back.
- Do it, man!
- I can't believe
I'm this strong.
- Let me go, let me go!
- Look at this,
I'm one arming it!
I can't believe I'm this strong.
- Let me go
- Look at this man,
I'm holding him back with one finger.
He like a little baby.
He can't get past me.
He like a little...
Ow, what?
- I'm a little baby?
- I'm holding you back, man.
- (beep) stupid, man.
- I got carried away, I apologize.
- What you mean you got carried away.
- You told me to hold you
back, I was holding you back.
What do you want me to do?
In a fight situation,
no means no, and yes means yes.
- How would I have known that?
(punch hits)
- Come on, man, ow, come on, that hurt.
God!
And you holding me back now?
Thank you very much for that.
(punch hits)
Okay, well just at least change it up.
Okay, now you listen.
(laughs)
Oh, hold on a second.
(slurps)
Oh hell no.
He did not just text me he working late.
That (beep) is weak.
- Okay.
You know what?
Working late my ass.
If he don't walk through that door
in the next half an hour,
he may as well not even come home tonight,
'cause I'm not going be there waiting
for his cheating ass.
- Okay.
Playing, you know what I'm saying?
I mean, I mean, I will be
there waiting, because...
But he gonna have to put up
with a lot of (beep) from me.
- Okay.
- And if he think he going
do this (beep) again,
he is sorely mistaken.
- Okay.
- Because my man gets one chance.
- One.
- Okay.
- And then after that he get one more.
- And then after that he
gonna get three strikes.
Then you out.
- Okay.
- And if I ever find out that my man
was messing around on me,
he better get as far away
from me as he possibly can
because he do not want to
get what I'ma give to him.
- Okay.
- I got my mother (beep)
real estate license.
- Okay.
- But if, and when he does
come home, that's fine.
- Okay.
- Cause he can go out and get all turnt up
with these little side
hoes and whatnot 'cause
you know what bitch, he
always going come home.
All right.
- Okay.
- I'm the queen bee, and he
always going come home to me.
You know what...
- Okay.
- But you know what, but you
know what, but you know what?
I don't even care!
- Okay
- But I'll tell you what happen
if he do come home.
- Okay.
- He ain't gonna be the want
any that (beep) in my house.
- Okay.
- He can come to the house if he wants to
but he ain't never gonna
do that when I'm home.
- Okay.
- You know what?
Even if I'm home, it's fine.
- Okay.
You know what I'm talking about?
- Because I don't give a good God damn.
- Okay.
- That's what I'm talking about.
But he ain't gonna bring
that (beep) into my bedroom.
I'll tell you that much right now.
- Okay.
- Cause ain't no triflin'
ass (beep) gonna wake me up
while he's cheating on me in my bed again.
- Okay.
- And I told him, I
looked right in the face.
I said, this is the fifth and last time!
- Oh kay!
(pop synth music)
- I couldn't have said it
better myself, girl, you right.
- Okay.
- You just been spouting
words of wisdom all evening
and I ain't listening to
God damn thing you sayin'.
- Okay.
I don't even know what
the hell I was thinking.
Girl, you right.
The second that that man
walks through that door,
I'ma dump his ass.
- Oh
kay.
- Okay.
- [Peele] Okay.
- Oh my gosh, speak of the devil.
(romantic pop music)
- Oh,
kay.
Okay.
(electronic synth music)